crowds of people move through the
Haitian Capital Port-au-Prince they're
angry over a rising cost of living and a
lack of jobs and the prime minister's
decision to ask for help from other
countries to calm unrest
this man shouting against the need for
foreign troops
the police respond with tear gas
unemployment the High Cost of Living
insecurity it is for all these reasons
that I'm in the street
Haiti's economy has almost ground to a
halt since a coalition of gangs blocked
a major fuel terminal last month
the lack of gas and Diesel has crippled
transport and forced businesses and
hospitals to close
the Prime Minister has asked for U.N and
international help in the form of troops
he urged the International Community
including members of the security
Council to consider as a matter of
urgency the request by the Haitian
government for the immediate deployment
of an international specialized Armed
Force to address the humanitarian crisis
the latest unrest has also led to a lack
of clean drinking water that has caused
an outbreak of Cholera
the last case was reported three years
ago following an outbreak in 2010 linked
to U.N peacekeepers ten thousand people
died as a result
many people in Haiti say international
support has never helped them before and
they want the prime minister to resign
this request is an unconstitutional act
this is an act against the state it is
an action against the Haitian people's
demands who want a free country where
everyone can eat have health care and
live like human beings
Haiti has had 12 Prime Ministers since
an earthquake in 2010 flattened homes
and infrastructure in many areas
since then the country has received more
than 13 billion dollars in Aid however
most are still struggling to even afford
food and clean water
Leah Harding Al Jazeera